l'étoile aveu est cachée là quelque part
mais la confier même pas une minute
jamais même pas une seconde moi
[Musique]
et quoi avec ses yeux
regarde ses yeux te force de le croire
c'est vrai titre ça mignon
oh petit regarde
précieux sont encore plus gros que les
tiens fais tout ce qu'elle te dit Potter
mais une barbe à papa non avec les
papattes trop forte avec le chapeau
c'est pas mignon je suis en surface
on peut regarder la carte maintenant
non tu ne voles pas je viens ton second
souffle-moi aussi
toi lance-moi
et vous autres doubler la cadence
[Musique]
écoute docteur merci pour tout c'est
gentil mais je me sens très bien fort
remonte
comment te dire
tu es mort
docteur pitié
c'est moi les chats potés je rigole
devant la mort
et les chats ont 9000 d'accord mais tu
es mort combien de fois déjà
j'en sais rien j'ai jamais compté et
pour tout dire les matins on est fâché
tu es rendu à ta dernière vie un bon
conseil terminé les aventures c'est
l'heure de la retraite moi à la retraite
des antéocylomoriste du village